the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so the question was if you have this
these two these two lines right here
which I'll just put them up here just so
it's bigger type five print three point
zero minus one what is going to be the
output so if I run this in the editor so
for these types of problems you can
always check yourself and this comes
back to if you're new to programming
don't be afraid to try it out don't ask
me don't ask your your neighbor just
type it into the into the shell and hit
run and then you get to see what the
answer is
so the answer to this question is going
to 2.0 right and let's see are we right
yep
great 75% of the people got it right
perfect
so if you didn't get it right just to
explain again the reason why this
doesn't get printed out is because we
never actually had a print statement
okay so if you want to show something to
the console you need to use a print
statement